candidates arrive in the stage was set
voting now underway three contenders
with pictures looking to become
Scotland's next first minister
fast and awkward concession from Ash
Regan as she failed to explain what's
needed to set up an independent currency
so you need a central bank what about
the other institutions you need
what other institutions are you talking
about you don't know
the independent debt management office
right I'm sure as I said I don't have
this detail on this at the moment for
Kate Forbes it was yet again on social
issues where she lacked Clarity or
should be allowed to live freely as they
choose and I do not think that there
should be a that there should be
conversion therapy gay man adult man if
he wants therapy to change his sexuality
should that be allowed or not well it's
it's it's it's his choice and but I do
not think we should allow conversions to
this Choice well we should not allow
conversion therapy in Scotland that's
what I do hamster Yusuf tried to exploit
a perceived weakness of Miss Forbes a
party once famous for its Unity its
discipline now on the attack isn't the
reason you're losing SMP support is
because as that exchange with Bathurst
one you're not able to give a really
straight answer to a really straight
question on our Progressive agenda and
that's going to lose our support Hamza
Yusuf now Health Minister but previously
transport and Justice this a domestic
record he was forced to defend good
governance matters so a good Health
Service matters dealing with the economy
matters I mean what would you do to
deliver for example economic growth in
our economy and why do you think I'm
more trusted to tackle the cost of
living Christ the question you are
that's what I suspect because you've not
had a public service delivery at all but
I've had three of the most difficult in
government over the last 10 and a half
years how are you going to deliver
Independence if the public don't have
confidence in you they do and for three
weeks I've managed to increase public
support quadrupled in fact an hour as
much about division as it was detail or
policy by the end of the month one of
them will become leader there's a lot of
patching up to do bath Rigby Sky News
Edinburgh